Misereor, one of Europe's biggest children's charities, fights for destitute children and youths in the developing countries.
But year after year, Misereor faces a much bigger challenge: raising donations, however, small.
But how do you show that as little as two euros can move a lot in the third world.
Misereor presents the power of a coin.
With just two euros, you can support health care in India...
...or agricultural project in South Africa,...
...education for farm children,...
...electricity supply and sponsoring sports in Liberia,...
...or cultural funding in Argentina.
At the end, your photo appears...
...ready to be shared with all of your friends on Facebook.
A myriad of blogs and press articles were dedicated to this interactive billboard.
The message?
No matter how small your donation, there's a power in every coin.